wir sind ja noch mal auf der Gamescom wo
wir ja das wahnsinnig fette Youtuber
Treffen hatten und hier Alberto war ja
auch dabei servus Leute oder auf jeden
Fall richtig cool ich dachte ich komm da
an sind halt ein paar Leute irgendwie
aber das war richtig richtig voll es war
echt fett auch mal die anderen Youtuber
zu treffen echt ziemlich groß ja KLE ja
auf jeden Fall und W Trash ist nicht
schon was für eine Ironie haben wir
einiges gelernt und genau darum geht's
nämlich wie viel Leute da waren wir
haben ein paar Giveaways bekommen von
sehr cool auf jeden Fall hier ein paar
nette tächen von Google auf jeden Fall
noch Google Blocks also auch sehr fett
und natürlich auch diese Cap die ich
hier auf hab zwei Stück davon zwei Stück
davon also sind echt schon coole Sachen
die gibt's auch nur in Google Shop zu
kaufen die könnt ihr irgendwo anders
bekommen schon quasi exlusiv absolut
exklusiv und die könnt ihr gewinnen ich
habe in der Community Link unten im
Infotext einen ein eine Veranstaltung
eingesetzt die heißt Gewinnspiel
Youtuber treffen und ihr könnt schätzen
wie viel Leute wir glauben dass bei
diesem Youtuber treffen dabei waren das
darf du jetzt nicht sagen okay das war
eine Menge oder ja schon aber ich ich
sag jetzt du sagstber n okay okay ihr
müsst es schätzen wir haben uns eine
Zahl überlegt die realistisch ist und
ihr die Regeln sind genau drunter ihr
könnt dann eingeben wie viel ihr schätzt
die Regeln stehen da bei der
Veranstaltung und unter denen die die
richtige Zahl geschätzt haben werden
diese Giveaways verlost 5 4 2 also Leute
gibt Gas das sind einige dabei es kann
natürlich nicht jeder gewinnen aber ich
würde mitmachen es lohnt sich immer ja
absolut auf jeden Fall und Alberto ist
dann demnächst bei uns zu Gast auf jeden
Fall bis dann
Ciao
perfekt